Dark Souls remastered releases on the
25th of May which should tide us over
until we hear more about shadows die
twice later in the year on screen I'm
going to put all the new specs for your
systems and these frame rates they
passed the test it's going to feature a
six player online in PvE or PvP which is
up from four players and it's also going
to include the new password systems that
have been included in recent games which
is a really great addition we'll also be
getting dedicated servers for what I
believe is the first time which has
interesting implications going forward I
always wish that they would invest a bit
more in their PvP systems and this is a
sign that they're doing that and finally
a number of bug fixes and improvements
have been submitted by some members of
the community in the past year or so so
you can expect the more egregious
problems in the game to have been
addressed
probably apart from all of that though
we know very little about how much of a
pure remaster this is and Namco has been
really quick to clarify that the game
will not include any new assets based on
the Dark Souls 3 engine or any combat
differences but no combat differences
really Dark Souls ones engine has aged
quite a bit and I'd be very surprised if
they didn't tweak a few small things
like backstabs or omnidirectional
movement while you're locked on and I
think I speak for most people here when
I say I'd also love to see tweaks to
some of the rushed areas of the game the
obvious example that everyone is
throwing out is lost izalith and
you know I can't imagine being from
software and not wanting to fix these
examples of rushed development after all
these years yes there's a certain magic
to keeping them exactly the same that if
Kaos is kind of special because of how
terrible that boss fight is but there's
a really strong argument to be made for
tweaking a few things as well and with
the introduction of dedicated servers
for what I believe is the first time I
can't imagine that they'd be leaving
covenants untouched as well especially
with how bare-bones they were in Dark
Souls 1 so I wouldn't lose hope
regarding some nice upgrades to the
gameplay just yet but bear in mind that
there are no promises on this front all
evidence at this point indicates that
this will be a remaster that is very
similar to the experience of Dark Souls
1 but regardless of how much they change
and while I do hope they change a lot
and keep it fresh it's gonna be a hell
of an experience for new and old players
alike because to so many of us Dark
Souls is what started it all it's the
gold standard for level design in souls
because it has that amazing interwoven
map structure that I really wish they
replicated more in future games this is
the game where I fell in love with PvP
the hardest and now there's going to be
this new huge resurgence of players just
ripe for invasion and it's the game with
the characters who were so well designed
that their souls persisted throughout
two sequels and their stories are the
ones that inspired prepare to cry which
was the series that put this channel on
the map so with that in mind and I've
been waiting a long time for the perfect
moment to announce this I'm happy to say
that prepare to cry will be remastered
alongside this game with better audio
better footage and you know all the
tricks that I've learned through the
feedback that you guys have given me
since those golden years when
first started those stories deserve it
man they're so good
you deserve it and this is the perfect
opportunity may 25th is gonna be one
hell of a nostalgia trip with you guys
and we should be able to ride that
nostalgia high ride into December which
is the absolute latest by which we've
been told to wait for details regarding
shadows died twice
and speaking of shadows died twice which
is kind of the reason I made this video
I have a few more revelations that I'd
like to attach to this video that I've
discovered since making the last one on
shadows die twice so firstly a ton of
you guys responded rightly to that video
with the question how come nobody has
translated the Japanese script in the
trailer background and translating that
was one of the first things myself and
many others tried and we all ran into
the same roadblock which was that these
are not modern Japanese characters in
fact they're so ancient that they're
barely discernible from Chinese and
they're written in such a cursive you
know calligraphy heavy style that it
makes a series of sequential characters
really hard to read and identify my
partner was able to identify the words
in Chinese for fish tiger shape and
maybe even blood but at the end of the
day this might just be gibberish not
necessarily meant to be translated but
the most important thing you know
regardless of whether we can translate
one or two words is that our resident
translator lore master Naga has said
that there are Japanese specific
characters here and that they have a
calligraphy style that places this era
in a period before the Edo period
but after Late Antiquity so now we have
a time and place in history to sort of
work with here the best very appropriate
reference that we have is neo which
actually takes place right before the
Edo period
Japan as well and it sets up this world
where the clans of Japan were at war
with another and clashing for control of
Japan and once you insert a supernatural
force into the mix like in neo and maybe
in blood-borne if this is a blood-borne
game you have a hell of a story here in
a setting that from software hasn't
visited in a really long time
and speaking of blood-borne there have
been a few other links to blood-borne
discovered in the trailer by user
Kordofan on Twitter who points out the
striking resemblance between this chisel
and the chisels in Garmin's workshop
which is a discovery that goes hand in
hand with the next little tidbit which
is that some of the runes on gomen
scythe actually look a lot like Japanese
there's a ton of good speculation I'm
gonna put in the description down below
I have a feeling all of this speculation
might come to naught because we do this
every year when they announced a new
game but they're teasing us for a reason
they want us to speculate and it's fun
to speculate and when it's not
blood-borne and all of this gets proven
wrong we still had some fun times
guessing because what else are we gonna
do until Dark Souls comes out and we can
get our souls fix but thank you all for
watching I'll see you in a couple of
days because I'm about to dive into the
cut content of blood-borne and I'll see
you then
oh and before I go it wouldn't be a
party video without diving into the deep
deep lore behind this one-minute trailer
now if you zoom into the bonfire here
yeah that's it and then enhance the
image